oui oui il faut aider les entreprises en
temps normal mais aujourd'hui après le
film en plus que jamais qui diplômé
d'une école de commerce je viens du
monde de l'entreprise j'ai moi même créé
une entreprise et je sais ce que c'est
d'être confronté à l'inconnu et en ce
moment il faut vraiment aider nos
entrepreneurs de chez nous devons donc
bien sûr accompagné ces entreprises
c'est ce que je fais déjà séjourné par
rapport à des questions par rapport à
des questions surtout administratives et
l'accompagnement est un rôle principal
pour pour l'élu et sur notre ville pour
accompagner à toutes les entreprises
nous avons aussi des atouts majeurs sur
notre territoire de l'autunois de
l'autunois-morvan prendrai l'exemple de
ce qui est de l'agriculture de ce qui
est également les valeurs et notre
richesse de nos forêts exploitées au
mieux tout ce qui est la filière bois
nous avons nous-mêmes paie un plan pour
les commerces de centre-ville en
annulant des taxes sur les terrasses
attaque sur la publicité extérieure
mais il faut également aider les
entreprises en la rassurant en ce moment
chiffre d'affaires et ça ça passe par
les investissements par la commande
publique par les travaux et alors que de
nombreuses collectivités ont décidé de
rester les travaux nous nous avons
souhaité au contraire rajouter des
travaux